[Musique]
saint frajou dans la haute garonne
georges dufort 56 ans paysan célibataire
mène seule l'exploitation hérité de sa
famille la solitude est devenue pour lui
quotidienne et objet de réflexion
[Musique]
depuis quand vivez-vous ici dans cette
maison mais ici nous vivons et nous
avons acheté la maison en 1933
j'ai perdu mon père en 1957
je vis seul au milieu depuis 1957 mais
je vivais en compagnie de ma mère j'ai
perdu ma mère il y a c'est tant mieux
mais mes parents mes grands parents
étaient cultivateurs
mon père était cultivateur mais vous
auriez peut-être grands parents étaient
cultivateurs mais moi je ne les ai pas
connu qu'en fait ils ont que toute notre
famille toutes trois générations que
j'ai connus étaient trois générations de
cultivateurs et comment était votre père
mon père c'était tout notre réseau net
retrait de loire qui mené sa barque eux
d'une main très ferme
c'est à dire très ferme de refaire mais
vous savez des ongles dans le dans le
monde paysan vous avez vous avez une
bonne 2 et 3 c'est déjà ne pas vous ne
devez pas à lui ni à droite ni à gauche
je sais que vous avez un chemin très
précis à suivre et on ne vous demande
pas si vous voulez suivre vous pouvez le
suivre
comment se passer les rapports justement
chez vous ici et les enfants avec le
père abbé le rapport à leurs pairs vous
savez le l'enfant à partir de l'âge de
12 ans devait écouter c'est à dire qu'il
n'avait pas le droit de parler quand le
père quand le père recommandé son fils
ils devaient le fils n'avait pas de
nombreux départs ne demandez pas si vous
vouliez faire un travail
on me disait vous devez faire ce travail
disons que dans la cellule familiale
tous les gens avaient leurs tâches la
mer suivait souvent le pl dans les
travaux des champs la mère restée à la
maison
elle faisait souvent on ne veut pas dire
s'occuper à s'occuper des petites bêtes
c'était une personne merveilleuse la
grand mère elle ramène a du reste ce
n'était pas la seule erreur masters le
lendemain même c'était disons tout de la
grand-mère de toute la grammaire disons
de partout enfin la grammaire la grand
mère paysanne si vous voulez c'était une
femme travailleuse et merveilleusement
belle et merveilleusement bon aussi mais
je vais vous raconter un tout petit peu
comment elle me considérais moi je
l'aimé beaucoup mais aussi mais beaucoup
et je dis que le plus grand cadeau
colombie se faire a dit le grand mail
c'est de lui faire des petits enfants
parce qu'elle adore les petits enfants
et je me rappelle quand j'étais jeune
quand j'étais jeune j'avais deux ou
trois ans et ma grand-mère qui quand
elle avait fait la cuisine s'occuper des
bêtes c'est à dire la regarder elle
allait garder les cochons elle m'a mené
avec elle alors le manchot parler
j'étais très bavard je parlais beaucoup
avec elle en occitan bien sûr parce
qu'on ne parlait pas français du reste
manger quand j'ai été à l'école je ne
peux parler très peu le français
alors je trouvais que ma grand-mère a
malgré tout était assez agi je retrouve
étrangement j'étais jeune j'avais 12 ans
je retrouvais réagir avait les cheveux
gris blanc
elle avait une figure de tri demetri
vers encore était souriante
alors j'ai utilisé ma tout jeune je le
disais tu sais que je serai grande je te
faire éteindre les cheveux parce que je
trouvais qu'elle avait les cheveux
blancs et je te ferai tant dans les
cheveux puis je la trouvais un petit peu
âgées je lui disais je te fallait mettre
du sang neuf voyait déjà je passais à la
transfusion moi j'aurai deux arrêts tout
ça en occitan
dans le midi sinon nous étions une
région très pauvre
les gens n'avaient pas beaucoup d'argent
mais il avait beaucoup de coeur dans
toutes les propriétés surtout dans les
petites propriétés
vous avez encore la grande mer
[Musique]
je veux qu avec maman seule pendant 22
ans
on en a beaucoup travaillé il avait eu
quatre enfants et quatre enfants assez
disciplinés ce pas et elle a beaucoup à
raconter
elle était si souvent au coin du feu et
le recommandait souvent indigents que la
une vitrine de la faire la cuisine tant
qu'elle a pu
elle était très fatiguée très malade il
y a eu un moment dans sa vie où on ne
peut plus aller au jardin
alors moi même j'allais au jardin je lis
porter tous les légumes
je lis mettait sur la table et l'a fait
elle a fait la cuisine elle a fait la
cuisine jusqu'au dernier moment mais
quand maman n'a pu faire la cuisine
elle n'a pas tardé à nous quitter et se
peigner par exemple quand l'avez-vous
fait je fais ce poignet il ya très
longtemps je faisais beaucoup de paliers
je faisais beaucoup de paniers que je
donnais à des amis et un jour le moment
me dit mais pour moi tu ne fais pas de
panier alors je lui ai dit écoutez moi
je vais te faire le plus beau et je lui
ai fait ce beau panier voyez que c'est
celui là évidemment il a été toujours
pour elle je la gardais en cours je
regarde toujours
et comment se fait-il que
aimant autant cette cellule familiale
que vous n'en ayez pas créer une vie
mais c'est à dire laisser passer ceux ci
c'est que les paysans après la guerre il
avait tellement souffert de la guerre
quand il avait un garçon ou une fille
il gardait le garçon pour continuer
l'exploitation et il a mené c'est à dire
qu'il faisait étudier la fille
il faisait de la fille est seulement un
peu une fille qui avait étudié qui avait
été en vie le nouveau les généralement
pas revenir à la campagne
évidemment le cultivateur était en règle
avec lui-même puisqu'il avait assuré la
succession de sa propriété mais en
faisant étudier sa fille
ils avaient pénétré le nombre il avait
privé un de ses voisins d'une compagne
voilà à peu près ce qui s'est passé et
puis vous savez ici
si attendant vous n'êtes pas mariée vous
avez presque vous n'avez presque pas de
chance à vous marier c'est à dire que
vous avez en rayon vous avez un rayon de
20 km et comment se déplacer très peu si
vous n'êtes pas mariée à 30 ans il ya
pratiquement on ne peut plus se marier
ne croyez-vous pas que pour un paysan
est indispensable d'être mariée bien sûr
mais j aimerais soufflé mot sur le site
de l'accident
c'est un accident parce que j ai
évidemment le cheminement de londres
n'est pas fait pour être seul il doit
être un couple est plus que le couple
même la série le familia faire un tour
vous mettez un nom mais sur un tracteur
a nommé sur un tracteur il est à sa
place
conduire à une exploitation seul c'est
comme si vous demandiez à l'aune de
conduire le tracteur la fois voilà à peu
près voilà peu près pendant ce temps
dans ce que les difficultés les
difficultés de l'art du paysan quand il
est seul
mais vous savez le travail le travail
bon ça compte de monsieur sur tout ce
qui est très difficile c'est qu'on peut
rentrer vous avez vous avez votre repas
faire et ça c'est très dur
[Musique]
ici le paysan disait souvent quand il
était seul qu'est ce que j'ai de plus
cher c'est l'eau du robinet quand c'est
l'heure du robinet le plus fort vous
savez il ya pas grand chose dans la
cuisine mais en seconde on se débrouille
toujours il ya toujours moyen de faire
la cuisine vous avez des yeux puis je
fais un tout petit peu de 2 confie j'ai
de la peine il ya toujours en plus j'ai
mon potager c'est à dire j'ai toujours
de quoi faire la cuisine
je me suis équipé de la cuisine avance
depuis à peu près sept ans avant je
faisais la cuisine au feu c'est à dire
que je lui même on peut il fallait que
je fasse de la braise j'avais un tout
petit fourneau je m'étais cette braise
mais c'était très long c'était long la
compagne du paysan cependant pendant
l'hiver c'est d'abord le feu puis c'est
d'abord le faire quand il rentre parce
que c'est la première des choses qu'il
fait mais la compagnie du paysan c'est
souvent c'est souvent la chienne ce sera
sa petite chienne qu'il a à côté de lui
enfin d'autres façons de paysans des
passeurs de notes sur une exploitation
parce qu'il y a en plus il y a plus les
vaches disons qu on peut dire que le
paysan n'a pas une solitude complète et
puis il a tellement de travail qui n'a
pas été il ne fait pas ça nuit il n'a
pas quand on me demande si je m'ennuie
je le dis je n'ai pas le temps
[Musique]
o o
alors quels types de cultures fait vous
ici alors je fais du blé je fais de la
boyne je fais du maïs mais pour les
salaires le set où je ferme plus la vie
un peu de pommes de terre
mais c'est à peu près tout je suis
mécanisée à peupler depuis lequel elle
est emmenée dans un hollandais sinon
j'avais toujours travaillé avec les
vaches j'ai travaillé la terre impôts
doute marie ève la main c'est à dire les
deux tiers de mon existence je
travaillerai les bêtes je ne contienne
je ne fais contient seulement le
tracteur de 15 en un peu plus de ma vie
sinon j'ai toujours travaillé avec les
bêtes et souvent à la main que c'est une
culture de triberg la culture de la main
si on si le psy la main du paysan on
pourrait parler c'est une même l'artiste
si on compte tout ce que fait la main du
paysan à partir du mois de janvier
jusqu'au mois de décembre
on peut dire que chaque mois la main à
son travail
vous avez le gestionnaire qui étaient
investis dénombre que l'on fait que l'on
fait de moins en moins du reste mienne
c'est elle ne s'y était pas trompé lui
qui avait magnifié ce geste il ya trois
ans j'ai été à une enfant à paris il y
avait une exposition millet et je
regardais le tableau du summer
j'ai trouvé ça merveilleux j'ai trouvé
ça merveilleux ces temps de grand beau
qui se mêlent aux grains à pleines mains
et qui se met la vie et puis j'ai été
frappé par il ya un tableau qui m'a qui
m'a plu c'est l'angélus de millet je ne
sais pas du reste je ne sais pas du
reste ce que représente le tableau
exactement j'ai vu des gens ce nom mais
une femme qui avait qui avait rempli un
sac
ce sac était sur gourette je me rappelle
bien il ya déjà trois ans de ça ce sac
était sur une boulette il était fermé ce
sac d'os ces gens là avaient fini le
travail et je suppose qu'ils ont dû
ramasser des pommes de terre n'en suis
pas sûr
je ne sais pas la composition du tableau
ils ont dû ramasser des pommes de terre
et vous savez quand on a ramassé des
promoteurs c'est très dur c'était de ces
gens là qui rêve qu'il y avait beaucoup
peiné aurait pu repartir en sifflant
vous voyez de monsieur ont pu repartir
la tête très haute et c'est pas ça du
tout quand il a quand il a entendu leurs
élus cet homme
cet homme est découvert il a baissé la
tête et moi je les trouve une magnifique
retour et plein d'humilité
cet homme est très digne en même temps
avec sa dame à ses côtés je trouvais ce
tableau merveilleux
[Musique]
le paysan selon mme qui aime la terre le
paysan c'est encore long nous que l'on
trouve sur la petite exploitation
moi je défends beaucoup la petite
exploitation
parce que c'est encore là que l'on
trouve les gens traités les salles
[Musique]
l'essentiel de mes bêtes salive h
célébration
je sais d'ailleurs des vaches que jeudi
le monde revenus n'est ce pas je n'ai
comme je ne connais vraiment révolue
mais à mon sens ça me suffit j'ai plus
de rapports maintenant avec les bêtes
café la terre parce que je fais pour moi
c'est plus facile d'avoir un entrepôt
que de cultiver sur 26 hectares que j'ai
j'en ai un peu près 10 de cultivables
mais tout le reste je le laisse en
pacage ou un prêt de fourche la petite
propriété voyez c'est la richesse d'un
village c'est une richesse de la france
et personnellement je crois qu'il faut
conserver à tout prix la petite
propriété parce que la petite propriété
c'est là où on trouve encore l'homme
très sage c'est là où on trouve une
façon de vivre très douce c'est là où on
trouve l'homme qui peut parler qui sait
s'arrêter
et la télévision je voulais depuis 7 ans
8 ans peut être à peu près non en fait
je voulais l'acheter il ya dix ans mais
je suis un petit peu attendu parce que
ils font tout petit peu des idées des
choses je trouve qu'actuellement on
allait chose de trop vite
elle ne les apprécie pas le moment le
plus pénible pour l'homme est seul c'est
le mot c'est par exemple le d'image
c'est le dimanche
vous savez que tous les gens sont réunis
vous vous êtes seul et alors à vous
ennuyer beaucoup les plus lus moments
les plus pénibles en plus ce sont les
jours de fêtes par exemple je vais vous
citer du moment où je m'ennuie beaucoup
c'est par exemple le jour du 1er de l'an
et le soir de noël
parce que là vous êtes le seul événement
sera long cours que je sais que tous les
gens sont réunis moi je suis seul ici et
vous savez un homme et soeurs ici qu'est
ce que c'est et si vous voyez nous
étions sept autour de cette table
maintenant ici je suis seul
et qu'est ce que c'est la vie d'un homme
seul la vie d'un homme seul c'est une
table c'est une chance et une assiette
une chaise votre chien à côté de vous et
puis c'est tout
puis n'y a plus rien
ils ont tant que vous avez cette moto
alors il est à peu près 27 ans est
permis de conduire automobile vous
n'avez pas passé même récemment pour toi
non je ne vais pas passer parce que j'ai
perdu mon père à 34 ans j'avais 34 ans
je suis resté seul avec ma mère disons
que je n'ai pas eu le temps de passer le
permis
je me suis retrouvé seul sur cette
propriété ça a été impossible de passer
le permis
je n'ai pas pu me dégager et votre père
rectifié de permis à cette époque il ne
faudrait presque pas en parler de passer
le permis s'était tout de suite après la
guerre il y avait très peu très peu
d'auto et comme on ne pourrait pas fait
de tournée soit j'en avais pas je
n'aurai pas à passer le permis
vous allez vite élections vous savez
vite dans les descentes oui dans les
centres est formidable de 60 à l'heure
il fait pas peur
évidemment quand elle a une cote quand
elle voit une cote comme ancêtre est
férié
[Musique]
où vivait en ermite 12 mois sur 12
non pas tout à fait parce que je dois
vous dire qu'en plus du blé du maïs je
cultive aussi l'amitié
j'ai beaucoup de gens qui viennent chez
moi des jeunes en particulier
disons que j'ai des jeunes il vient
souvent pendant les vacances
et en période de gros travaux jusqu'ici
tous les jeunes qui étaient venus qui
sont venus une fois sont toujours venus
et m'ont fois il ne passe pas au moins
ça mais qu'elle irait disons que je
reçois beaucoup de cadres et des jeunes
qui m'explique que souvent ce qu'ils ont
ce qu'ils ont appris à la campagne en
fait ce que j'ai pu leur donner ce que
la nature leur a apporté et disons
qu'ils ont trouvé le pays magnifique et
contre eux on peut dire que c'est un
grand investissement
je vais vous lu une lettre que j'ai reçu
une lettre parmi tant d'autres georges
un jeudi quelconque dans un lycée gris
un cours de philosophie sur la
sociologie bruno comme souvent pense à
celui qui visiblement là bas au pied des
pyrénées avec des roulettes
tu ne peux pas imaginer à quel point
nous avons été marqués par ce séjour
nous en parlons souvent présentes ont
souvent à propos des poules et des coqs
ou encore nous revoyons la sortie des
vaches grands moments de la journée pour
le mans pour ma part je pense souvent la
tonification alors que moi je meurs
d'ennui et de cafards au lycée
aujourd'hui je laisserais tout pour
venir te voir charger une brouette de
fumier magie d'une belle tranche de pain
de campagne m'asseoir à la table de le
matin alors que quelques rayons de
soleil revienne à ses couleurs sur la
table sombre quand la pendule eux sont
de 10 heures à bientôt un green ou
encore sur la magie de la vie paysanne
bruno
je suis plutôt gai disons que j'ai une
vie très dure mais qui s'est déroulée
dans un éclat de rire
c'est à dire c'est à dire que y demande
vous savez les instants durs de la vie
on les met un tout petit peu de côté et
puis après on prend les bonnes choses de
la vie autrement on ne peut pas avoir
on ne peut pas avoir toujours les
mauvaises choses aujourd'hui quel âge
avez vous
j'ai 56 ans vous comptez travailler
jusqu'à quel âge mais je ne sais pas
vous savez le paysan généralement qui
travaillait jusqu'à sa mort en feignant
dans la retraite alors ils arrêtent un
peu plus tôt enfin disons que je suis
comme tous les gens ce seul mais je suis
assez inquiet j'avais un petit neveu je
croyais qu'il allait reprendre mon
exploitation mais il ne va pas le faire
alors je ne sais pas comment je ferais
je n'ai aucune idée
j'ai la même inquiétude que tous les
gens qui sont ceux qui osent aussi
compter sur une personne qui finalement
fini seul vis seule je ne vois pas je ne
vois pas vraiment ce que je peux faire
disons que je vais continuer de
travailler tant que je pourrai utiliser
et lorsque vous ne travaillerez plus la
solitude veux pas vous paraître plus dur
d'être seul ici de toute façon je ne
sais pas dans ma vie je ne pourrais pas
je ne pourrais pas rester seul je
critique un tout petit peu les maisons
de retraite
enfin pour les gens ce qu'ils vont enfin
pour les hommes pour les hommes qui sont
seuls je crois que c'est une très bonne
chose
j'ai une compagne bergère je dois vous
dire que c'est une chienne merveilleuse
je dis souvent c'est la meilleure chaîne
de la haute garonne
mais ce n'est pas assez c'est la
meilleure chaîne de france mais elle me
dit encore le mieux et je dis que c'est
la meilleur chien une masse du commun y
at-il dans l'année de longues périodes
où vous ne voyez personne vous n'avez
l'occasion de parler à personne mais ça
m'arrive assez souvent surtout en
période de travaux on parle de travaux
quand je suis dans les champs
vous savez c'est sidérant de la maison
disons que nous rappelle un il m'arrive
parfois de passer trois ou quatre jours
sans parler et quand vous avez passé
trois ou quatre jours sans parler on
attendait plus de son de votre voix
alors que ce que je fais moi je parle un
petit peu en machine et j'entends de
nouveau ma voix sinon c'était
désagréable mais ce que vous pensez que
la solitude soit quelque chose de
naturel pour l'homme
non je ne crois pas je ne crois pas la
solitude alain pas naturel toute façon
l'homme n'est pas fait pour cheminer
seule ils doivent cheminer admet enfin
vous savez je suis seulement il faut que
je m'échauffe il vouziers de fait je me
suis fait plein de fois difficilement
m'enfin on peut supporter la solitude
eux mêmes avaient le sourire
chez le paysan il ya toujours une
certaine philosophie de la vie et je
vais vous raconter une petite anecdote
que il est un paysan je connaissais un
paysan de ces bons vieux paysan très
sourire toujours la cigarette au coin de
la bouche c'était de normes et et les
philosophes ils avaient de très
mauvaises récoltes chaque année c'est à
dire qu'il avait cinq ou six sacs de blé
5 ou 6 ha de blé
cc c'est rien du tout c'est pratiquement
rien du tout alors il y avait des
voisins qui lui demandait comme ça est
ce que tu as été riche cette année
alors il répondait mais n'atteignait y
passe temps
ce qui veut dire en français j'en
attendais pas autant
c'est at il était très avait cinq ou six
ans de blé alors que ces 5 ou 6 ha de
blé ce n'est rien du tout j'ai vu cet
homme toute ma vie le sssa l'apl à la
philosophie paysanne c'est à dire que le
paysan doit être heureux avec ce qu'il a
[Musique]